a ticket agent sells 42 tickets to a
play the tickets cost 29 each use
rounding to estimate the total dollars
taken in from the sale of the tickets
now if we wanted the exact number we
could say 42
42 times 29 and we could work out the
multiplication but they essentially want
us to be able to do it in our head we
want to round the numbers first and then
multiply so if we want to round and
really we just have two places here so
we're going to round anything it's going
to be to the nearest 10 because that's
the largest place we have so if we round
42 to the nearest 10 we've done this
drill many times
2 in the ones place is less than 5 so
we're going to round down the nearest 10
is 40. we're going to round down to 40.
29 if we round to the nearest 10
9 in the ones place is greater than well
great greater than or equal to 5 so we
round up the nearest 10 is 30.
and another way to think about it just
say well you know 42 that's pretty close
to 40. 29 is pretty close to 30. those
are literally the nearest multiples of
10 that i can figure out so now i can
multiply
so now you can multiply and here once
again we can use you could call it a
trick or hopefully you understand why it
works but 30 times 40 instead you can
say well this is going to be the same
thing as 3 times 4 but we're going to
put two zeros at the end of it 30 times
40 is the same thing as 3 times 4 with 2
0's let's do that so you have 3 times 4
is 12 which we know and then we have two
zeros we got that zero so let's stick
that zero there and then we get that
blue zero there so let's put that over
there so we're going to have they're
going to have a
roughly 1200 dollars taken in from sales
of the tickets that is our estimate